welcome to this video playing just like
music from the US can I do something
else for once okay let's let's try this
opening the the rest of opening usually
black goes t5 but ok I'm sorry transpose
to to learn yeah let's see after you
fire food Heather's cannot philidor set
up energy to our this this is
interesting move g4 available if he goes
if you play Knight bd7 first so no d5
let's see if it's an expert on this I
think black usually plays h 6 cm
well if he doesn't I just play g5 and
push the light back 'if I've like II
five g5 and well cutie it's a yeah he um
he found it now I'm just by Bishop g2 92
it's kind of setup thought that's
interesting that's interesting really
hmm c5 okay maybe it takes Queen takes
two let's go to a Sicilian type of
position this is a game of structural
transpositions between the defaulting
then we had no I was expecting a
pitifully door type of stuff and we have
a Sicilian all of a sudden okay let's
see ok be fire film but so not much
development for black my next move will
be F for from probably no matter what
well if you place g5 either i don't play
a form o Queen 85 and it's hard to play
this without talking beyond
and yeah interesting and form
and B 495 night if I cannot believe that
you can take on you for really maybe we
can but it's sudden you escaped or
should I spend move on on a three-year
this is very lame come on let's just
let's just push be for 95 94 others in
Queens it to where I didn't I didn't see
that at first ok well the Queen here in
fact allows me to play g5 94 94 the
queen is hanging so let's just let's
just push him
I am such an idiot 94 94 2292 bishop h1
the rook is singing you can just take
you for basically win nah no not not
winning but very close to that okay so
this was a successful bluff ah what the
heck before
95 94 really I'm look up now but maybe
he is arguing that he's got a big attack
it coming that's possible Wow rookies
hanging and my penis is completely out
of play whoo interesting now maybe you
can really just take between 8-4 I can
take thee too though I know my queen is
back in the game this is very important
can take what i can take here i can take
f form
what Bishop deform should be four maybe
however Bishop deform
nope this one is for getting the Queen
back but I need to get the Queen back
into the game then probably at this
there's more than one move that wins but
I think this is the most convincing it
covers many critical square c5a for
where the Queen were black screen might
get into the play and I'm attacking me
for so he needs to move the bishop are
protected and then i can safely take
detours a form being a look up
okay voice is ticking here
hmm the relatively actively good defense
I didn't I don't really see a direct win
now interesting okay
check
now here you can after taking at least
turn and Tom be one
that's a really wacky game oh not coming
be one check this a surprise check
we've taken 26 earlier check time
warning check check check check check
check check black or if it's on time wow
it really took took a long time Queen B
1 words was much more annoying but this
this was just crazy really crazy stuff
and that was probably probably losing at
one point let's let's let's check this I
mean maybe this was too lazy should have
played there for earlier with this yeah
this is not working at all you can just
take your phone the thing is I come
after I overlooked that I was looking
heifer if we looked at now my rook is
saying so I need to do something else
and something else is not really great
iam and like taking here yeah it's just
it just complete crap something
something like like this and this is
just as ruin why does just just losing
yes sir yeah here you just needs to take
on g7 with with a murky position like
that I know it's completely crazy i
don't know what's going on and TM I'm
really just a hookup but it's it's a bit
confusing Bishop deform yeah also a good
news but this isn't bad really check it
should keep the winning hand and yeah
this helps a lot to get stuff
coordinated you should give yes check
computer wants to play Bishop see one I
think I would have played that one yeah
computer is just on plus two women
certainly have spoiled some of my
advantage but it should it should be
enough really not very a very
complicated game thanks for watching